we're told that tomer has a bookshelf
the table below shows how many books are
on each shelf so the first shelf has 19
books the second shelf has 24 books the
third shelf has 32 books and the fourth
shelf has seven books
how many books are on the bookshelves
all together so pause this video and see
if you can work that out before we work
through it together
all right now let's work through it
together so if we want to figure out how
many books are on the bookshelves all
together or on the bookshelf all
together we essentially have to add 19
books to 24 books to 32 books to seven
books so really this is going to be 19
plus 24
plus 32
plus 7. that's what we really have to
figure out now how can we do that well i
like to do that by separating out the
tens place from the ones place for
example i could rewrite nineteen as ten
plus nine i have one ten and nine ones
one ten
nine ones i could rewrite 24 as 20
plus 4
so plus 20
plus 4
i could rewrite 32
as 30 plus 2
and last but not least i could rewrite
let me find a nice color here maybe i'll
use blue i could rewrite seven actually
i won't rewrite seven seven only has
seven ones so i'll just write seven
right there
and now what i can do is i can take each
of these
that are that have that were cut came
from our tens places right over here so
i would have 10
plus 20.
i'm just crossing it out so i can keep
track of things plus
30 plus 30 so i did these three and then
i would have all of the
ones or the things that i got from the
ones place and let me do that in orange
so it's the 9 the 4 the 2 and the 7. so
plus 9 plus 4 plus 2
plus 7.
now
what's 10 plus 20 plus 30
10 plus 20 is 30 and then that plus 30
is going to be 60.
another way to think about it i have 110
plus another two tens which would give
me three tens plus another three tens
which would give me six tens so that's
60
and then how do i think about this
well i can do this in any order i can
see that 2 plus 7 that's going to be
equal to 9
and i can see that 9 plus 9 is equal to
18. so this is going to be the same
thing as 18
plus
4
and then let's see it takes 2 to get to
20 and then i have another 2. actually
let me write it that way
so i could also write this as 60 plus
and if i just take 2 from the 4 and put
it onto the 18 this would be
20
plus 2
this and this are equivalent and the
reason why i did that is it's easy now
to add 20 to 60.
20 to 60 that's two tens plus six tens
that's going to give us eight tens
that's going to be 80 and then 80 plus 2
is of course going to give us and we can
have something of a drum roll almost
have the answer 82 that's how many books
tomer has all together